it's the job of law enforcement to have
guns and to decide when to shoot you
just do not want the average citizen
carrying a gun in a crowded place former
New York City Mayor Michael Bloomberg
made that comment after an armed citizen
may have averted a mass shooting by
killing a gunman at a Texas church it
hasn't aged well how convincing can
Bloomberg's only cops should have guns
message be to Americans who have seen
and shared fresh examples of unjustified
and brutal police conduct or who have
witnessed scenes of rioters and looters
putting their lives and property at risk
because law enforcement agencies failed
to protect them the NYPD and the mayor
did not do their job last night a good
many Americans took responsibility for
their own safety including people who
fully support protests against police
misconduct but see no reason to allow
themselves to be victimized by hotheads
and opportunists in st. Paul Minnesota
black residents stood armed guard
against looters outside local businesses
business owners in Kirkland Washington
did the same a Bellevue Washington cigar
shop owner chased off looters at
gunpoint they were acting in the
tradition of the so-called roof Koreans
who defended their stores during the
1992 LA riot think one of his purposes
is the ones potential looters to see it
I think he wants people all of them up
there want people to see that they are
armed and that you enter their
properties at some risk many police
departments conceded the limits of their
abilities in Florida sheriff Grady Judd
advised Polk County residents to shoot
looters high-profile psychologist Scott
Barry Kaufman a gun control supporter
marveled on Twitter that when he called
Santa Monica Police over protests
related confrontation they told him sir
the city is under attack do what you
have to do for those who have been
advising Americans for years that we
should lay down our own weapons and
trust armed government employees to
protect us and treat us with respect
2020 has been a massive reality check
the year so far has demonstrated once
again that the police can't be relied on
to defend our lives and property and
often pose threats themselves it's the
job of Lawrence
to have guns and to decide when to shoot
if we were to follow the advice of those
who would disarm us we'd be even more at
the mercy of Derek Chauvin and his
buddies and anybody else with ill intent